From an art heist gone horribly wrong to the
most messed-up body horror nightmare in years,
these are the best thrillers
you already missed this year.
Gerard Butler's action thriller, "Plane,"
got buried early in 2023 due to little
marketing and no momentum heading into
its January release. That's a shame,
because it's honestly one of the actor's best.
This action-packed adventure follows
pilot Brodie Torrance as he's forced
to crash-land a plane onto a remote island,
where his passengers are taken hostage by a
local rebel faction. With the help of
one of his riders — a former soldier
accused of murder — Brodie must rescue his
passengers and help them get off the island.
"I'm telling you that the
way home is on this plane.
I got you this far, I just need
you to trust me this one more bit."
"Plane" features one of most harrowing
crash-landing sequences you'll see in a movie,
and it perfectly sets the tone for the
incredibly tense fights that follow. All
the great suspense and strong chemistry between
Butler and actor Mike Colter help lead the film
to an undeniably epic firefight finale. Sure,
Butler's action thriller flicks have been a
little one-note in the past — but despite the
simple title, "Plane" is far from generic,
providing viewers with the kind of thrill
ride that audiences are always searching for.
Anyone that's seen director Brandon
Cronenberg's previous films "Antiviral"
and "Possessor" know that he's a modern
master of sickeningly twisted thrills,
much like his father David. The
younger Cronenberg's latest project,
"Infinity Pool," takes viewers on a luxury
vacation that takes a sinister turn.
Struggling writer James — played by Alexander
Skarsgård — gets the death penalty when he
accidentally kills a man with his car. He's given
a bizarre proposition, though — for a fee, James
will be cloned, and the clone will be executed in
his place. It's a choice that continues to haunt
him as he descends into a depraved criminal
underworld that pushes him to his limits.
With "Infinity Pool," Cronenberg once again
manages to elicit plenty of "icks" from the
audience. There are moments that'll leave
viewers tense and disturbed — especially
when Mia Goth's performance and
that signature Cronenberg body
horror are involved. "Infinity Pool"
may have slipped past wider audiences,
but that doesn't mean that its incredible crime
thrills and gripping horrors should be ignored.
"Maybe think of it as a gift."
Back in 2018, Sony Screen Gems delivered a
breakout hit with "Searching," in which John
Cho gives an unforgettably gripping performance
through some stellar webcam thrills and a twisty
mystery. It's possible many fans of the first
film don't know that an equally great sequel hit
theaters in 2023 — largely because it's called
"Missing" rather than "Searching 2," and it was
buried by a January release. Like "Searching,"
"Missing" utilizes its web-based premise in smart
ways as young June uncovers disturbing truths
about her family after her mother disappears.
"Missing" is an unbelievable thrill ride
that's guaranteed to leave viewers shocked
by its unexpected turns and wild twists. Storm
Reid's lead performance perfectly leads audiences
through all the chilling discoveries June
makes, keeping viewers hooked right up
until the supremely tense and explosive finale.
Given how popular "Searching" was when it hit,
it's baffling that "Missing" was just
thrown under the rug by Sony. That
doesn't mean that this is a movie worth
forgetting about, though — far from it.
Whether he's playing a lighthouse keeper,
the Green Goblin, or Jesus Christ himself,
Willem Dafoe never fails to turn in
a standout performance — and that
definitely applies for 2023's "Inside."
Still, fans of the actor may have missed
the heist-turned-survival flick that stars
Dafoe alongside… pretty much no one else.
Dafoe flies solo as Nemo, an art thief whose
latest job goes terribly wrong after a security
system malfunction leaves him trapped inside
a luxury apartment. While a penthouse suite
might not seem like such a terrible place to
get stuck, it quickly becomes a living hell:
his escape options are severely limited, and
the security system constantly fluctuates the
apartment's temperature between sweltering heat
and frigid cold. As Nemo's situation continues
to grow dire, his sanity starts to slip — and
that's when Dafoe's performance truly captivates.
"I have no energy I have I'm dying
I'm dying I'm dying I'm dying I'm dy—"
"Inside" provides some good survival
thrills and inventive moments that'll
get viewers hooked from the start, but
it's Dafoe's one-man show that'll really
leave an impact. Nemo's slow descent into
madness and disjointed reality makes for a
harrowing watch — one that will keep you
guessing up until the very end. "Inside"
got completely overshadowed by "Shazam: Fury
of the Gods" when it hit theaters, but that
doesn't mean that audiences should miss out on
its uniquely intriguing premise and performance.
Not every thriller needs to provide painful
moments or chilling turns to be a highly
engaging ride, and Guy Ritchie's criminally
underseen "Operation Fortune: Ruse de Guerre"
is proof. This star-studded adventure follows
a team of spies as they recruit a movie star in
an effort to stop an evil billionaire arms
dealer. "Operation Fortune" is essentially
Ritchie's take on a James Bond spy adventure
— and it makes for a hilariously fun time.
Ritchie's signature style of comedy works
perfectly in creating some very funny and
engaging moments from the highly talented cast
— which includes Jason Statham, Aubrey Plaza,
Josh Hartnett, Hugh Grant, and Cary Elwes.
The action is fast and fierce, and there's no
shortage of wild gunfights and thrilling chases.
Based on the film's poor box-office performance,
"Operation Fortune" clearly wasn't on a
lot of radars when it hit theaters — but
better late than never when it comes to
watching this highly entertaining romp.
Since the pandemic delayed the release of
"Operation Fortune," two Guy Ritchie films
ended up coming out in the first half of
2023. The second one was "The Covenant,"
which made it to theaters in the U.S. just
a month and a half after the director's
previous effort — and while it's also a quality
watch, it couldn't be more different in tone.
"The Covenant" is set during the War in
Afghanistan and stars Jake Gyllenhaal
and Dar Salim. Sergeant John Kinley and his
Afghan interpreter Ahmed help innocent people
survive against the Taliban's growing shadow
— but when Ahmed's family becomes threatened,
Kinley must take matters into his own hands.
Along with Gyllenhaal and Salim delivering
great performances, Ritchie helms some
incredibly suspenseful firefights that are
bound to leave viewers hanging on the edge
of their seats throughout all the close-calls
and unsettling suspense. The entire last act
is a true fight for survival, which makes for
a very satisfying and cathartic conclusion.
"The Covenant" arguably got overshadowed by
the breakout success of "Evil Dead Rise,"
but that simply means that
Ritchie has a killer double
feature full of amazing lesser-known
thrills waiting for people to experience.
When it first debuted, critics praised Daniel
Goldhaber's activist thriller "How to Blow Up
a Pipeline" for its solid script and impressive
ensemble cast. Despite its instantly compelling
title, though, the reverse heist flick didn't
gain much popularity in mainstream circles.
Inspired by author Andreas Malm's 2021 book of
the same name, "How to Blow Up a Pipeline" follows
eight young people as they plot to destroy
oil infrastructure in West Texas. The film's
environmentalist message and philosophical
conundrums are front and center — after all,
our heroes never quite decide whether what
they're doing counts as terrorism or not.
"American empire calls us terrorists,
then we're doing something right."
From a narrative perspective, the movie's most
significant achievement is its ability to get
viewers invested in the individual stories of
all eight members over its 100-minute runtime.
Things only become more nerve-shredding as the
group goes deeper into crafting their plan,
the stakes ratchet up, and things start to go
horribly wrong. "How to Blow Up a Pipeline" is
full of shockingly explosive moments and
gripping turns that'll leave viewers stunned.
It's no surprise that an international thriller on
Netflix can end up being overlooked — with so much
content on the service, it's easy for something to
get lost in the shuffle. Of course, that doesn't
mean that subscribers should miss out on "Kill
Boksoon," an incredibly fun South Korean thriller.
Gil Bok-soon is both an assassin and
a single mom, whose life and flawless
success rate on the job are put into jeopardy
when she finds herself in a kill-or-be-killed
conflict. Director Sung-hyun Byun shows
some great prowess in crafting thrilling
and engaging action sequences that aren't afraid
to spill some blood, keeping viewers hooked on
every punch and slash. Whether it's through brutal
hand-to-hand combat or with a variety of weapons,
the titular assassin absolutely makes her mark
on her foes — and the audience, in the process.
"Kill Boksoon" features a great cast of
characters with distinct personalities,
and a slow-growing conflict that boils over into
a shocking finale. It's a shame that great movies
like "Kill Boksoon" can easily be missed — so
you should definitely add it to your watchlist.
Since it was also dropped onto Netflix without
much fanfare, fans of the BBC One show "Luther"
might not realize that a film continuation
called "The Fallen Sun" hit the streaming
service in early March. The film sees Idris
Elba reprise his role as disgraced detective
John Luther as he tries to right the wrongs
of his past and capture the serial killer who
continues to haunt him. Elba returning to this
role will definitely feel satisfying for fans,
but the movie is also an excellent
gateway for newcomers to learn about
one of the actor's most iconic roles.
"The Fallen Sun" is a very solid serial
killer hunt with twists and turns that'll
keep you guessing at how things will end.
If Idris Elba wasn't enough of a draw, "The Fallen
Sun" also features great supporting performances
from Andy Serkis and Cynthia Erivo. There's rarely
a moment to catch your breath, and you never truly
know when things are about to get brutal. Whether
you're a longtime "Luther" fan or someone looking
to get a taste for what it's all about, "The
Fallen Sun" is a thriller worth checking out.